les 25 et 26 novembre prochains se
tiendront les premiers états généraux
des violences faites aux femmes
deux jours de débats de témoignages et
des changes dans le but d'apporter des
réponses adaptées aux situations de
violence conjugale en fait il mobilise
toute la société immobilise toutes les
personnes publiques toutes les
partenaires institutionnels et toutes
les associations s'est montré que la
réunion ensemble arriverai à convaincre
et à combattre ce fléau
donc c'est particulier parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas juste de se retrouver entre
professionnels c'est particulier parce
qu'il ne s'agit pas juste de de débattre
et échanger c'est des paroles qui
doivent se traduire par des actes c'est
aussi la mobilisation de la société et
des citoyens il faut que tout le monde
les hommes les femmes les enfants les
jeunes les personnes âgées les
réunionnais les réunionnaises puissent
un jour dire stop
on en a marre on peut plus tolérer les
violences qui sont proférées à l'égard
des cas depuis le début de l'année
quatre femmes ont été tuées par leur
conjoint la réunion cinq plaintes pour
violences sont déposées chaque jour dans
les commissariats une situation
alarmante
malgré les dispositifs de prévention et
de prise en charge existe donc sans
peine les téléphones pour grand danger
pour les femmes il ya eu
des instructions données aux services de
police et de gendarmerie pour il
recueille systématiquement les plaintes
il ya des intervenantes sociales
également qui font beaucoup de choses
il ya des associations qui se mobilisent
il ya des foyers d accueil qui sont
prévues pour les femmes et leurs enfants
mais ça ne suffit pas pour qu'on voit
d'abord comment mieux se mobiliser les
états généraux des violences faites aux
femmes seront animés par des partenaires
institutionnels ainsi que des
représentants d'associations
mais la particularité de ces rencontres
c'est son ouverture au grand public pour
que tous se mobilisent et s'engagent à
changer les mentalités